what's the biggest dick you've had to
handle on camera
like 12 13 inches
yeah that's like my [ __ ] four dude
it's i was
watching it so like i we were shooting
content it was being dread
and i he had it on the ipad so i could
see it and i could see it like going in
my ass
and i had to poke it in your head and i
had this moment where i was like this is
what people feel like watching the
footage of their own colonoscopy
like i don't want to know this about
myself so i just like looked away
you took 12 did you enjoy it oh yeah it
was really fun
it was fun we got pizza afterwards pizza
oh no watch the game about pizza forgot
to watch the game
we listen to steely dan we both really
like stealing dan
that's absurd i can't even
you're right you can't [ __ ] make that
[ __ ] up
you're listening to reeling in the years
after that
holy [ __ ] that is unbelievable
[Laughter]
is there anything you did in porn for
the first time in your sex life
that you had i mean other than being
waterboarded and chilling yeah
right uh oh i had never fisted anybody
you fisted someone yes i actually won an
award for it this year
what a world what is it the golden fist
wow that's a better name
it's just best fister best foot come on
the golden fist
it's so much better what a girl or a guy
uh it was a girl um and she was actually
one of my very good friends at the time
and we worked together for kink and i
fisted her [ __ ] and i was so
i was so nervous the whole time because
i'm thinking [ __ ] no
nope straight up in there i mean like
how deep
oh my god and i have little arms but
like
that's not little yeah for an [ __ ]
for an [ __ ]
you put your whole arm of her butt i was
so nervous too i was like
i would be too yeah yeah okay and i'm
normally never like that but at that
i was oh my god and she was into it yeah
have you ever been fisted
um yes in your butt
i can fist my own butt i don't ever i
don't let anyone else do it i can do it
to myself
you don't laugh no yeah how do you
practice that
uh okay so the way i found out i could
do it i was uh
in the bath and i was a little stoned
and
i was like playing with my butthole and
i was like i wonder
i just wonder so i like grabbed some
lube
and i started doing it and it went in
and i was so excited that i i lived with
my boyfriend at the time this was way
before i had a point
i jumped out of the tub and my fist was
still in my [ __ ]
i had my grandmother was like baby look
at this kind of look at this
this is the most outrageous [ __ ] i've
ever heard and he's like you're getting
the carpet all wet
[Laughter]
and your fist is up your butt i did not
care no enthusiasm for this whatsoever
yeah but is that something you get off
on like is that something you put into
your personal sex life
like you can fist my butthole i think i
have a weird
like disparity dichotomy i'm not sure
the word um
between like that kind of sex in my like
purse like
when i like sex for like with someone i
care about that i really like like it's
just
organic and it sucks but i also kind of
you're open to whatever it's just
organically happening yeah like okay now
we're gonna come over here and i have
this weird mentality where i think i
kind of look at
sex on some level as like an endurance
sport where i'm like
like i want to like push like to me that
stuff isn't necessarily sexy it's just
cool
it's like weird it's funny it's fun like
it's just cool
you know i don't necessarily think of it
as like hot
if that makes anything that makes sense
yeah
so what like
if you're taking a fist then a dick's
got to be all right then
uh some of those dicks are the size of
your arm there's no doubt
yeah i've seen those girls to put it up
next to their face and i'm like oh my
god out of their arm and i'm like oh my
god
right like i i mean everything stretches
but yeah like especially like in my
[ __ ] like i
don't have like i have a very shallow
vagina that's part of why i like anal
especially like in porn
because it's a it's easier it doesn't
you're not like hitting my cervix
um but like yeah whenever i talk to
people especially like in regular life
like
dude six to seven inches is fine like
that stuff that 14
13 12 inches [ __ ] like that's cool on
camera i don't want to do that on a
tuesday every day yeah
no i want to i like because whenever i
bring that guy up people are like oh my
god imagine having a dick like that i'm
like yeah
imagine you think you're like gonna have
a girlfriend who's gonna [ __ ] you
multiple times a week like do you that's
not gonna happen
yeah i bet it though yeah it happened
like that's probably why they getting
porn it's the only time they can
probably really get laid consistently
yeah
like a guy with that dick yeah
jesus christ you're blowing my mind over
here
[Music]
[Music]
you